¡Buenos días! Hoy firmamos
1 acuerdo entre podemos y Alianza Verde
para IR juntas
a las próximas elecciones europeas del 9 de junio,
las próximas elecciones europeas.
Está en juego el futuro de Europa,
la Europa que queremos
y dentro de esa Europa que queremos, sin lugar a dudas
la lucha por 1 Europa más ecologista, más Verde,
por 1 Europa que realmente
de manera transversal entienda la necesidad
de que tenemos que seguir avanzando
en esa en esas transformaciones
para hacer el futuro sostenible, es clave.
En ese sentido
nos incorporamos con entusiasmo a esta candidatura
impulsada por impulsada por o encabezada
por Irene por Irene Montero
y Alianza Verde
ha iniciado ya su su proceso de de primarias express
para elegir a nuestros candidatos y nuestras candidatas
que irán que irán en esa lista
como como digo, con el objetivo
de conseguir 1 Europa transformadora,
1 Europa diferente,
1 Europa que avance
en derechos y que avance especialmente
en la transformación
ecológica que necesitamos y en 1 futuro
para nuestros hijos y nuestras hijas.
Muchas Gracias